Next, we're going to work on the crowd controller class.
So I'm going to the third person example map tab.
I'm still in this third person BP blueprints folder.
And I'm going to right click in an empty space in the content browser, go to blueprint class.
And I'm not going to use any of these common classes because this is pretty specific.
And I'm actually going to expand the all classes section right here.
And I'm going to type in crowd and see which options come up.
So AI controller, that looks promising.
Detour crowd AI controller, that's the one we're actually going to use.
And I just happen to know that this specific blueprint works with the navmesh, which is what we need.
So click on detour crowd AI controller, hit select.
And we will call this crowd controller.
There we go.
And then double click on that.
And go to your event graph.
And if for some reason you don't have this event graph tab, I'll close it.
Then another way you can get to it is just double click event graph on the left underneath graphs.
And it's back.
So let's talk about this type of blueprint class.
Now, AI controller, that class is the parent class of what we selected.
We selected the detour crowd AI controller and an AI controller think artificial intelligence when you hear that.
And this class, it fakes being a person.
It doesn't listen to human input.
It listens to the environment, to game logic, and it reacts accordingly.
Now detour crowd AI controller, it's a child of that.
It has a pathfinding component, which talks to the navmesh for pathfinding and collision avoidance for the agents that it's controlling.
So let's hook this up.
So I'm back in the engine.
I don't need event tick.
I just need functionality that happens once we hit play.
So I'm going to delete event tick.
We don't need that.
And then I'm going to drag off of the execution wire for our very first node.
And overall, what we're going to do is we're going to tell any spawned non-player character to find a random spot within a radius of the navmesh.
You know, and then move to that and then repeat over and over again.
So first things first, let's just type in move to.
Let's see what options we have.
Now, I'm going to pay attention to these options that are underneath the navigation category, because I know that those know how to talk to the navmesh, which is what we want.
Now, we're moving to locations.
We're not moving to a specific actor.
So that tells me move to location or simple move to location would be what I'd want to try.
Now, the simple move to location, it has fewer inputs than move to location and it gets the job done.
So let's use that one.
OK.
Now, we have two inputs.
The first one is controller.
Now, that is wanting to know, OK, which blueprint class is controlling all of these crowd agents?
And it just so happens that this blueprint class is the one that is doing that.
So in order to tell this node that this blueprint is the one that is the controller, you just left click drag off of the blue dot, type in self and get a reference to this blueprint.
OK, so that's the first input.
The second input goal is talking about a goal location.
It's a vector.
Now, this goal location, we are going to get our current crowd agent, find its location and then move it to a spot within a certain radius on the navmesh.
And then that will be the new location that we use.
So let's just right click in an empty space.
Type in get controlled pawn.
OK, so get controlled pawn, so that will get all of our crowd characters.
So if you have two crowd characters, it will get two.
If you have ninety nine, it will get ninety nine.
And then the next node to get its current location, it's a context sensitive node, meaning I have to drag off of this node in order for it to appear in the list of possible options.
And then let's type get actor.
There we go, get actor location.
And click that.
So we have our crowd person, we have its location.
If we were to hook in the return value into the goal, nothing would effectively happen because we would be saying, hey, where is our crowd person?
Where is it? OK, move it to the spot that it already is, which is really boring.
So I'm going to move these nodes over to the left because we've got a couple more coming.
So next, if I left click drag off of the return value.
And type in. Get random reachable point in radius.
Notice it's under the navigation category, so it's working with the navmesh.
Click on that and make sure you change the radius to be something other than zero centimeters.
So I'm going to do three thousand centimeters.
We'll try that. And then now we can hook in this new random location into the goal.
And let's compile and save that, but it doesn't work quite yet.
We need to tell our non-player character to listen to our controller class.
They don't talk to each other yet. So if we go to the crowd character class and go up to class defaults up at the top.
Under pawn. We want to make sure that the AI controller class is not set to the original AI controller, but is set to crowd controller.
So the name that you see here should match whatever you typed for your crowd controller class.
OK, so switch that to crowd controller, compile and save.
And you'll notice the details panel when you have class defaults looks different than if you are selecting a component or something.
So the detail panel is context sensitive. According to whatever you have selected.
So let's go back to third person example and let's drag in a couple crowd characters.
OK. And then let's hit play.
OK, they moved once and then they stopped.
So let's view that one more time and maybe we'll add in a couple more characters.
Just so it's a little easier to catch.
OK, so let's hit play.
OK, they moved and stopped.
That one went a little further than that one.
OK. So I will hit escape.
Now, if for some reason this did not work for you, I would say, OK, double check the radius.
So if you go to the crowd controller, this radius, make sure that is not set to zero.
Make sure in your crowd character class under class defaults that the AI controller class is set to your controller class.
And then, you know, make sure you actually do have a nav mesh in the level.
And those would be the first three things I would double check if it did not work.
So we've got our crowd characters set up and the crowd agents and the controller classes that talk to each other.
They work with the nav mesh. And in the next video, we'll make further adjustments to the movement and the speed of the characters.